[Music]
the Duchess was summery chic and a
sleeveless belted trench dress the pale
blush pink outfit is from The Canadian
brand house of noni it costs eight
hundred twenty-five dollars and is sold
out and only available on backorder the
designer tells ET megan has had the
dress in her closet for a while she
accessorized her outfit with pumps from
Dior and a mulberry handbag that matched
her dress royal newlyweds attended a
London exhibition honoring the life of
the late Nelson Mandela a pastel color
has become a favorite of the Duchess
she's worn it numerous times since her
wedding but there's one surprising
critic of her royal wardrobe her dad
Thomas Markel in his interview with the
British tabloid the son he criticizes
her Duchess looks saying quote Megan
seems like something out of an old movie
why in 2018 are we dressing like the
1930s why do they have to cover their
knees the former Hollywood lighting
director who believes his daughter is
faking her royal smiles and feeling
pressured by her new duties also told
the son that he wants to go to London to
try and visit her whether he's invited
or not saying quote I'm not going to
wave flags and make a fool of myself I'd
find a hotel room and try to reach them
you
[Music]